can like innovator you know he's he's
like with even with Tesla that wasn't
his company that wasn't his idea he
bought into it right
um but people and and one thing that I
think sums up Elon Musk he over promises
and under delivers constantly he said
we're gonna have you know people in Mars
by 2024. you know that's what is the
original statement and then he kept
changing oh no it's gonna be this now
it's gonna be this podcast is brought to
you by betterhelp online therapy my
friends get unstuck with better help
learn more and save 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com genius that's
betterhelp help help.com genius this
podcast is brought to you by
expressvpn protect your online activity
today with vpns with the VPN rated
number one by Business Insider visit my
exclusive link expressvpn.com genius and
you can get an extra three months free
on a one-year package that's
ex-p-r-e-s-svpn.com genius
expressvpn.com genius to learn more this
podcast is brought to you by rocket
money my friends get rid of useless
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com genius seriously it
could save you hundreds per year that's
rocketmoney.com genius cancel your
unnecessary subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com genius
in five four three two one Hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast
so I I [ __ ] had my first uh like
grappling wrestling class oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] love it dude yeah I want to just
smash everybody brother everybody it's
hard because my knees are so [ __ ] up
but I've been doing a lot of rehab on it
so now now I can shoot for like singles
and doubles
I want to just grab somebody and beat
the living [ __ ] out of them just walk
around just smashing people
number one number one I want to
literally grab if you guys have never
wrestled before or ever grappled
it is hard and it is so [ __ ] by the
way it's not like I did like a full-on
course it was Nick he was kind of giving
me an introduction to it and even for
like the limited amount of movement that
we did my forearms are sore [ __ ] right
just having to hold and grab somebody
for even like three or five minutes it's
really really tough yeah so when we
found out or what now we but what I
found out too was like
you know in any type of like physical
Combat Sports or martial arts right a
lot of it's like intuition the
difference between grappling and
wrestling and between like kickboxing
though a lot of it obviously is like
stuff that you do repetition that you
can see things in this instincts right
it's still visual there's like visual
cues when you see somebody faint or move
yeah when grappling at somebody's on you
you don't see [ __ ] right it's you
literally feeling everything out where
the weight shift is yeah so you have
zero knowledge you don't know what the
[ __ ] is happening that's what's so crazy
about it is that like I think a lot of
times when people watch sports but
they've never played any kind of sports
in their life they're like why aren't
you doing this why aren't you doing it
like they don't understand just how
difficult it [ __ ] is to do what you
think is so simple and then they forget
to factor in the fatigue part of it
right when you're that thing throw more
it's like bro it's only been two minutes
hey try sparring for two minutes
straight I guarantee you'll be huffing
and [ __ ] puffing at the end of that
there's a lot of things two like in
Combat Sports when you talk to Pro
Fighters there are people who they call
them like gym Kings like in the gym yeah
Untouchable and the reason why is not
because of their conditioning and
anything else the pressure isn't there
there's no lights there's no people
screaming and they're [ __ ] amazing
but when they go in that cage their
adrenaline starts to go and they have
issues with anxiety and they're like
dude if they can get that in control
they would be the next UFC champion
right and that's another factor to
factor in right that whole that's like a
beast on in and of itself is to be able
to perform under the bright lights maybe
even people booing you right being in
like a hostile territory I mean it's
there's so many different factors at
play and that's why you can't help but
appreciate guys like Habib guys like
Islam where they just execute with
perfection and they the way they're able
to dominate like that it's just like you
know they're about that [ __ ]
life that Pakistani wrestling and you
know they they're about that [ __ ]
life it's crazy too because like Nick
too obviously he's allowed me to have
like certain I don't know what I'm doing
right but he was you know giving me
examples of what people do and it's a
game of like inches next thing you know
like this full has me like in a
submission like I don't even know how
you got to this point yeah I don't know
how I'm here yeah and I'm in pain yeah
but like he I don't know what this move
is called like [ __ ] oh my God I was
like wait how did how did I get here
yeah I don't know how this happened
right so even for me you know watching
the UFC and obviously kickboxing for
like three years now or whatever like I
could see
it's really hard to be
a I want to say legitimate but to really
understand fighting if you've never
trained
um to a certain extent obviously if you
watch it you have opinions and stuff and
it's probably all correct to a certain
extent but you understand it more when
you start doing things so one of the
things that I've always had trouble with
uh watching UFC fights one FC Bellator
whatever that it is when it uh uh I
couldn't truly understand grappling
exchanges I understand like position
here and there but I don't understand
what they're trying to do because these
advancements and you know them trying to
gain position is all small things that
we can't see unless we've been in that
situation so it's hard sometimes yeah
and so even from this one time that you
know this one lesson that I did I start
to understand things a little
differently I'm like oh that's why that
person did that that's why DC always
says go for the single when they're up
against the cage because I never
understood why he's like I don't
understand why people just don't switch
from the double the single when they're
on the cage and it's just about position
and so
if like that type of stuff is very
interesting like being knowledgeable and
fighting to watch something it makes it
more fun now yeah because now we can see
now I understand like when people who
are very casual fans and they see
grappling exchanges they're booing
because they don't know what they're
looking right they just think it's
boring yeah they think these two guys
are trying to butt [ __ ] each other right
hey pretty fun too
I don't know why you're knocking on it I
mean come on speaking of fighting though
and I'm pretty sure I mean this is
probably passed for a couple of weeks
but uh I didn't really want to talk
about this only because like number one
I didn't even watch the fight I didn't
watch it because I already knew what the
result was going to be yeah I I already
knew off jump not because it's rigged
not because of anything else but
Anderson Silva and Jake Paul fought each
other right yeah uh people have been
requesting for me to talk about this but
I'll be honest with you straight up I
didn't watch it because I knew Jake Paul
was going to win and the only reason why
is because Anderson Silva is 47 [ __ ]
years old yeah and I know people are
saying well he fought you know Julio
Chavez uh junior and he won Police
Junior if you guys don't know has been
through a lot of [ __ ] you know drugs all
this other stuff you know
um
and at the end of the day like knowing
Anderson's style uh if you watched him
his record uh while he was in the UFC I
think he lost eight out of nine in his
last run it was skid yeah yeah it's been
like that pretty sad close to otherwise
epic you know career yeah 47 years old
and on top of that too I saw the way he
looked this one didn't take any steroids
I was so upset I if Anderson took a
little juice it would have been a
different story yeah a little different
story I'm saying trying to trying to be
on that Vidor Belford regiment
if he was trt V tour style yeah it would
have been a different [ __ ] story yeah
um but from what I've heard people say
that you know Anderson had a lot of
great rounds and a lot of people thought
it was uh Anderson one up until the
knock down knock down yeah which I heard
was pretty [ __ ] clean yeah it was it
was and and look
for a 47 year old he looked like he's in
pretty great shape just take steroids
bro please I beg you just take a little
but but also too you could definitely
see the age where his reaction was
slower the power just wasn't there you
know and it's like
it's frustrating from being an Anderson
Silva fan how he used to move so fluidly
and just so effortlessly you know
knocking people out with just a counter
punch like this right just it looks like
he barely tapped him and he's like
putting people to the ground right
um but he just he really didn't have the
same kind of power behind his punches
and the speed wasn't there either 100
like if if just even watching him and
people were looking at him you know
doing his mint work in his paddle
because I did see videos like that yeah
the technique looks great yeah but the
speed and [ __ ] wasn't there and I'm only
saying this because one of my favorite
videos that I've ever seen from Anderson
Silva outside of the UFC was him at
wildcard boxing with Freddie Roach and
he was boxing another pro boxer this was
10 years ago and this is when he was
like 38 and he was his footwork his
speed his timing was amazing yeah and
when I saw that padward even though it
did look amazing but it looked amazing
for his age exactly that's the caveat
here yeah but I will give credit to
[ __ ] Jake Paul man absolutely you
guys have to understand something and I
know a lot of people too May disagree
with this because they're saying well
you know he's fighting uh washed
Fighters a hundred percent true but the
other flip side to this right is that a
lot of pro boxers when they first start
boxing they fight a lot of shitty people
and not to the caliber of Anderson Silva
right pro boxers like you've seen it too
so you watched it in a boxing match uh I
only saw clips of this of that uh the
guy that um Logan Paul fought at first
KSI KSI fought somebody who he fought
two fights in one night and he fought
uh he [ __ ] phone
um this one Mexican pro boxer right that
boy was trash he was pure [ __ ]
garbage it's like he's never so bad he
looks like he never boxed a date he's
like how is this guy a professional
that's what I didn't understand a lot of
pro boxers when you first fight pro
boxing yeah are Fighters like that and
I'm saying this because I've seen it
right in the same thing like back like
in amateur uh MMA fights yeah it's a
mix-up sometimes you'll get the Phenom
right other times you'll get somebody
who's an amateur Pro that looks like
they've never fought a day in their life
or or it's very intentionally stacked
that way to pad your record 100 and so
the first few fights that Logan fought
it's questionable right obviously
somebody like Ben askren [ __ ] doesn't
have any hips one of the worst Strikers
in the in MMA history ever right through
yeah literally yeah who the [ __ ] cares
about that but he fought somebody like
Tyron Woodley who was known to knock out
people obviously on a on a fight skit as
well but Anderson Silva is not those
people yeah yeah right
when you look at somebody who is a
beginning as a pro boxer he him being
able to beat Anderson Silva even though
it was questionable for a lot of people
once again I didn't see the fight so I
have no opinion yeah
it's pretty [ __ ] amazing yeah you
know you could definitely see the
improvements and and Jake uh Jake's
skills as well and he answered one
question that went on unanswered up
until that point was can he go the
distance can he last can he go a full
eight rep I mean it wasn't obviously a
12 round fight but like he went the
eight rounds and he looked relatively
fresh it didn't look like he was like
just gassing out and huffing and puffing
so big props to him for like being in
shape continuing to improve himself
um and did enough to to get the dub on
this one man and you know the it kind of
made Dana eat his words because like
fight Anderson Silva yeah he was like a
year or so ago he's like I guarantee you
Jake will not [ __ ] fight in Anderson
Silva and he's like who knows maybe
Anderson Silva two a year or two years
ago he would he might have been better I
know and at that age it's so critical
like each year is so each year is vastly
different yeah yeah so like you know
Anthony Smith if you guys don't know who
Anthony Smith is you know if you guys
are not a fight fan I think this is just
an interesting conversation to have
anyways it's like Anthony Smith is also
a light heavyweight in the UFC right
commentator great fighter too yeah a lot
of fights in the UFC yeah
um and I think like his bone to pick
with
Jake Paul is that okay so the kid can
fight but
he still is a piece of [ __ ] to him
because he's like you are specifically
picking our beloved Legends yeah who
have been on the hugest fight skins of
their life they're at they're way past
their Prime these people who have Legacy
that they built built this company up
who have literally just bared their
cross and have fought their heart out
their best years are now behind them and
then you take them into this platform
and you beat them up like it's nothing
when you're in this 27 26 year old kid
who has all the money in the world and
you do that to people who are alleged
and you don't give them their due
respect that they deserve he goes that's
why he has an issue with them he goes
until you fight somebody who was at your
caliber or the caliber that we deem fit
for you then you're still going to be
questioned all the time which when he
says it like that it's 100 True right
right I give Miss Professor Anderson
Silva yeah but I still don't respect him
very much because you decide to take a
fight with a quote-unquote legend who by
the way is [ __ ] damn your 50 years
old right he's the man's twice his age
you know multiple surgeries destroyed
his [ __ ] Shin destroyed his knees
everything about this guy is torn down
but then the flip side to that is that
these are grown ass men making the
decisions themselves yeah
exactly they they see it as a Payday and
I don't really think they look at it as
in terms of like a legacy thing for them
they're like their legacy is already set
you know Anderson going into it because
he said it's like this you know this is
what I expected like he expected to lose
he didn't expect to win right
um
but yeah that what Anthony Smith is
saying is completely valid but then
let's bring in the payday into the
picture and then it changes the
conversation right yeah I mean I'm
pretty sure Anderson Silva you know I
think his upfront pay was like 500k and
then he has like a 35 of the
pay-per-view so you know he's probably
walking way close to a million right
which is not bad for nice work right I
mean not to mention other sponsorships
he might have gotten through this yeah
so I just hate seeing like somebody who
I who is my favorite fighter in all of
mixed martial arts history yeah
go down like I know I know that's that's
definitely the sad I care to watch it I
don't care to watch this [ __ ] freak
Show yeah and that's why I heard like
the pay-per-view not maybe the
pay-per-view advice or like the
attendance buys were trash like that's
the other thing that I think Jay Paul
doesn't realize is that just because
you're fighting Anderson Silva doesn't
mean that people still want to fight you
people who are or honestly washed and
old right because I'm a huge fan of
Anderson Silva but his fam Jake Paul's
fan base is what 12 years old 10 years
old they don't know who [ __ ] Anderson
Silva is yeah they don't really care to
watch this the freak Show is now done
we've seen you do this same Trope over
and over again of course the buys aren't
going to be that great because nobody
cares to see you beat up old people now
the shock factor is not there anymore
exactly that's why I didn't watch I
didn't watch the last time on Woodley
fight I didn't watch this fight either I
don't care to yeah the one that I was
going to buy was him fighting Tommy Fury
right right to see now that would have
been an interesting match yeah not
anymore Tommy first can get his ass beat
yeah Jake Paul has gotten exponentially
better and Tommy Ferry hasn't fought
since Tommy fair is going to get [ __ ]
up yeah I feel anyways yeah yeah no I
mean like I said you could definitely
see the Improvement and strides and Jake
Paul's game for sure but again the knock
there is still valid which is that he
hasn't fought anybody I mean has he
fought a professional boxer yet no right
yeah so he hasn't won fought a
professional boxer yet and two he hasn't
fought a professional boxer worth their
assault you know like that that actually
can compete with him at the same age
that's not 50 years old that's not on a
crazy fight like Anderson still like I
said I love him but time gets everybody
yeah man it doesn't matter like for
example if you guys don't know who Sugar
Ray Leonard is boxing [ __ ] Legend
yeah right and look he's like 60 years
old almost uh are you are you going to
reference that clip with Ryan Garcia yes
that was so sad to watch and I was like
something to watch [ __ ] sugar railing
is one of my favorite boxers of all time
he's a legend right actually so he's a
[ __ ] Legend his hands were like
lightning I know man you see him do the
uppercut challenge Garcia and his fast
for his age yeah but watching that [ __ ]
looked like he was moving hands
underwater man bro that [ __ ] made me
giggle a little bit it made me giggle it
did and I don't want to see that [ __ ] I
did it you know what I'm saying time
gets everybody that's just a factor yeah
it is what it is man so like for for
somebody like Jake Paul his next move
and the next fight that he has is going
to be a smaller buy unless it's like
another YouTuber like if he fights KSI
then it's going to have a lot of bicy
because both of their things combined
together right right but him fighting
like he's like I'm gonna fight Nate Diaz
nobody wants to see that [ __ ] Nate Diaz
is a 155er exactly exactly and the dude
is come on he's he's 100 pounds he's and
he's at the tail end of his career as
well yeah you know and he's never known
to be a boxer either yeah so if they
were to fight I think it's pretty given
that Jake Paul's gonna win that fight
it's hugely in his favor unless they do
12 rounds and Jake Paul gas and Nate
Nate Diaz is right
you know
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
is it just me or is does he get harder
and harder to understand the older he
gets I don't know if a CTE
no he didn't Mumble that badly when he
was younger though it it just got worse
maybe he's just getting higher and
higher the show so on the same card
there was a guy named Dr Mike and he
fought somebody that's in Nate Diaz's
camp and that guy talks just like Nate
Diaz both of them
it sounds like he bit his tongue really
hard before he started speaking he
always has like these weird inhale
I don't [ __ ]
and I was [ __ ] these guys over here
I'm like the [ __ ] I don't know what
you're saying yeah
hey when you know what the funny thing
is like people got mad at him for that
yeah I genuinely think he thought that's
yes you could clearly tell he wasn't
trying to be funny he was trying to give
the man props yeah like usually can fly
in his suit he thought that was his name
yeah I mean I guess there's something
wrong that he just defaults to Chung Lee
because that's like such a a wide known
you know he apologized to he goes hey
I'm trying to disrespect you I I thought
that was a name
but yeah this guy Dr Mike uh really
really popular uh popular YouTuber he
does like uh just medical he's an actual
doctor an actual physician okay ice
Buffy [ __ ] good looking as hell yeah
that's why all these
dick I get it I [ __ ] get it yeah you
know he goes in boxes uh
Guyana Napier's Camp he was also he was
in the USC for a little bit got cut he
went to a lot of different organizations
and he's not a great Striker himself you
know his record's not that great but
that full of Dr Mike got his ass beat I
did see that fight though yeah I wanted
to see it because uh like Dr Mike I
think he takes boxing very seriously and
I think he had a background in boxing
and stuff but dude you talk about a dude
that doesn't know how to move his
[ __ ] head to save his life yeah he
got lit up this dude got lit up same hit
too overhand yeah overhand think
overhand think
like what the [ __ ] are you doing man
like I get it though you know I give him
props because he went back in there he
wanted to prove himself he said that he
wanted to win this fight so he could
fight Logan Paul Logan Paul would [ __ ]
you up yeah Logan Paul's not a bad boxer
like yeah he lost the [ __ ] Floyd
Mayweather and you know not amazing but
Logan Paul would beat your ass Dr Mike
don't even [ __ ] think about fighting
moving he would absolutely destroy you
that boy is strong quick and fast and he
loves boxing right like people don't
understand like these guys yeah they're
not at the pro level boxes that you're
trying to see at but they're not like
some bums yeah they're not some Chumps I
mean they're they they're about that
life they're taking training seriously
yeah they got the best trainers on Earth
the most time and the most money right
they're gonna get better than the
average person it's going to happen and
they're already athletes yeah so what
the [ __ ] are you talking about that guy
Dr Mike got his ass beat dude I mean
it's not a surprise if it's his first
fight and you're fighting a second fight
oh his second fight okay and you're
fighting against somebody who is a
fighter regardless of of their record or
whatever chances are you're gonna get
lit up and that dude too like Dr Mike
was bigger than him the other guy was
smaller and he has like the Nate Diaz
buy to all flabby as [ __ ] yeah so he
just asked man is what it is dude yeah I
mean you know with the Anderson and Jake
fight it was a little bit strict because
I watched the fight because I was
curious of like how Anderson was gonna
perform at that age I didn't really
expect him to win you know but I think
it was like the first round and the
second round dude he did through like
virtually no punches you're just moving
that's Anderson Silva dude yeah everyone
was like what what are you like why are
you not even throwing a jab like what is
he doing right and so he just lost those
rounds by default because Jake was
actually throwing I mean nothing
significant landed but just he was more
active whereas Anderson was just moving
around and it was a kind of a confusing
tactic in that sense I'm like is he
trying to get him gassed out and then
he's gonna start going on the offensive
or he always I'm even in his previous
fights when he first started I mean he
definitely threw a lot more but he
always downloads data but yeah I'm
pretty sure he's trying to conserve his
energy because he knows his age it's
like you should be just taking steroids
I thought Jake looks like like he looks
like he's on something yeah it's because
uh his he's like 26 he looks like he's
35.
[ __ ] is with this kid I don't know man
that looks like he's on [ __ ] gear man
yeah but again
the dude is in shape you know even if he
isn't he's 26 27 he's young and [ __ ]
his [ __ ] venious [ __ ] in the car bro
I didn't look like that on 26 that's for
damn sure oh yeah let me tell you what I
look at 26. trash
you just go back to my old videos You'll
see exactly what I look like yeah
but uh one of the biggest things that
people are asking us to talk about is
[ __ ] Elon Musk finally buying out
Twitter for what how much was it 44
billion dollars something ridiculous I
had no idea you Twitter was worth that
[ __ ] much yeah it became such a huge
platform it was always like the the side
chick the social media I know uh and
it's it's so ridiculous that he
essentially bought it on a whim yeah you
know it was like almost a joke turned
into reality because he has the money to
be able to do something like that this
[ __ ] been firing everybody left
and right yeah yeah you know what the
crazy thing about that is
um people have been finding out the
salary of the people that have been
getting fired so the original CEO of
Twitter was let go right you know how
much her salary was per year I think
like 14 million or something 17 million
yeah right or Severance was 14 million
yeah it's ridiculous he was getting paid
17 million dollars of big tech companies
are making that kind of guap man that is
a joke I don't think Steve Jobs made 17
million dude
I don't know if maybe maybe in his
salary wasn't that high but he was still
you know worth a lot of money I think he
only won like a percent like one percent
oh isn't that he didn't own a lot okay
he I mean that's how you grow your
company yeah yeah relinquishes
everything else but it doesn't matter
it's a gajillion dollar company like a
percent or two is worth a lot yeah fact
check that please I don't really know
what I'm talking about uh I think I read
that in passing okay but she was getting
paid 17 million
um
if you let go of a lot of people and
obviously he's trying to you know trim
the fat in the company uh I don't know
anything about Twitter I don't know how
anything functions right but I do know
that there are a lot of companies who
are big who hire a lot of useless people
because I personally as somebody who is
who has to deal with brand deals and you
know going to these companies I know a
lot of people in those companies that do
not deserve a job there that they do
absolutely nothing and I have no idea
why they're hiring these departments out
like they show up yeah they just get on
a couple of emails they [ __ ] Chit
Chat around they go get lunch they come
back they do another few emails and they
pretend like they're doing work by
creating more work that is super [ __ ]
unnecessary yeah I deal with that [ __ ]
on a daily so I'm pretty sure I don't
I'm not saying that these are the people
who got fired but I know that when
somebody comes into a company and they
clean house a lot of these people are
let go because they're [ __ ] useless
yeah I mean that's the thing I don't
know if that is necessarily the case I
think it has to do a lot of with his
like uh biases that he had as well
because it's not like he did a thorough
audit and then these people
were let go he just started chopping
people left and right as soon as he you
know took over
um and it's
pretty it's been pretty entertaining to
see like how the whole thing has been
unfolding of like him trying to say okay
we're gonna charge twenty dollars a
month for the blue check mark and then
um uh what was it Stephen King was like
[ __ ] that you like you guys charged 20 a
month I'm out of here you guys should be
paying me you know and then he comes
back with okay how about eight dollars
are you serious
it's not a joke it became like the thing
now he's touting the whole eight dollars
it's gonna only go up to eight because I
think it was seven bucks or something
previously but it's only gonna go up a
dollar now
um so it's like
you know but it was like Twitter wasn't
profitable like there was no profit yeah
so he's that's what he's trying to like
Implement with with the increase in the
blue monthly blue check marketing right
is like his argument was hey man we
can't make uh money just from
advertising you know we got we need we
need Revenue
um he's like okay how about eight
dollars so wait do you could just buy a
blue check now or do you have to already
have one and then in order to keep it
you need to pay so yeah I think I think
there's still a vetting process for it
but then if you have it then you gotta
pay you know
um the the monthly amount and then that
makes you higher I guess or like index
better in their algorithm to become like
you know the official person of whatever
it is what is the purpose of it
I mean it's just verification I guess
that you are who you say you are you
know you know what's so funny too I know
that I've like I kind of vaguely heard
that and I've also just be on my Twitter
and feed constantly it's just these
celebrities saying like I'm out of here
yeah but then I check the next day and
they're still on
are you why are you celebrities so full
of [ __ ] like you do know that when you
write that out everybody reads it yeah
so they go I'm done with this platform
this is done and I'm like that's cool
but you're still there yeah you just
waited seven more times after you
[ __ ] liar because it's an addiction
they can't they can't get you know they
can't get away from it celebrities are
such full of [ __ ] dude they're literally
full of [ __ ] I mean it's it's hard to
like really blame them though because
look at look at their life look at how
things are like in their favor you know
it's like you got all of these uh people
praising them for every little thing
that they do uh or maybe not even
anything that they do just purely based
on the way they look they're getting
praised right let me tell you something
man
there are people online who do things
that are so bad but they get praised for
and it kills me on the inside I know I
know look a common like or I mean a good
example is kind of like the whole cyber
bullying of Pete Davidson when yay was
pretty much encouraging his fan base to
like hate on Pete Davidson and it's like
yeah people are like oh yeah that's
that's so funny you know that's so
that's so uh it's such a hilarious thing
that you're doing it yeah it's like ah
this guy's encouraging you to [ __ ]
like Bully somebody because he's dating
his ex-wife yeah
purely for that matter because he's
small he's a [ __ ] megalomaniac and he
can't handle the fact that somebody else
is bagging his ex-wife you know and
that's what I'm saying like That's why
nothing I and people don't really get
this when I say this like nothing online
is real everybody's a [ __ ] hypocrite
because those people who also are you
know a part of that [ __ ] yeah they're
also going on their [ __ ] uh their
what's called their moral parade
[ __ ] on other people about morality
it's like you have no right to say that
well Elon Musk has been on that tip and
and you know that that if [ __ ] like
just irritates me so much of like he's a
God to some of these people you know
that the cult like following that he's
built and and kind of the Persona that
he's built for himself he's he's like he
can do no wrong he can say no wrong and
it's just like bro look into this guy
man this guy
I'm not gonna go as far as calling him a
con man but he's he's not
like he's not a Tony Stark that's that's
what he's been painted out to be he's
he's the real life Tony Stark
this guy's a great [ __ ] marketer I
give him props for that he's a great
entrepreneur I'll give him props for
that but he's not a [ __ ] like
innovator you know he's he's like with
even with Tesla that wasn't his company
that wasn't his idea he bought into it
right
um but people and and one thing that I
think sums up Elon Musk he over promises
and under delivers constantly he said
we're gonna have you know people in Mars
by 2024. you know that's what is the
original statement and then he kept
changing oh no it's gonna be this now
it's gonna be it's so he just markets
really well and he just throws out these
outlandish ideas the hyperloop idea
that's not a [ __ ] original idea he
claims he make he claims it like it is
that that's his original idea but that's
a failure you know um so so many of the
things that he's doing is isn't
necessarily a successful thing but
people just [ __ ] gobble up everything
this guy said and then the whole thing
with the [ __ ] Dogecoin even like he
was playing into it and and [ __ ]
making people lose money because he's
joking about it like it's it's like uh
the next big thing you know when
maybe he's trying to be funny or maybe
he's trying to be sarcastic I don't know
but like it's hugely irresponsible for
somebody with a platform like that to be
talking about [ __ ] like Dogecoin is a
[ __ ] meme coin there's no value to it
there's absolutely nothing that has
practical usage for it it was literally
created as a meme coin and this guy's
talking about like oh yeah you know it
you know Dogecoin is it could be the
next thing you know like yeah and and a
lot of people that's the whole reason
why Dogecoin had that uh huge surge of
people buying into it because of Elon
Musk he was solely responsible for that
so there are people saying hey man SEC
needs to look into this [ __ ] like you
know yeah what is this guy doing but now
that he's you know the owner of Twitter
like it's it's been pretty funny how
things have kind of unfolded uh ever
since he took and the biggest criticism
that he's getting right now is that he's
it's it's the thing that people love
about him and hate about him because
there's two sides to this right is that
there's you know Twitter was becoming a
space of like too much censorship so
people prefer the place to be free of
zero censors do you know what that led
to
five times increase in people using the
n-word yeah
no that's literally what it led to I
mean I get it this is the this is the
weird thing though it's like for me I'm
not a major fan of too much censorship
right
um
the here the the reason why is because I
hate tick tock tick tock is the most
censored platform ever but it's the most
popular yeah it is like I literally put
up a video and I bleeped out a curse
word and they took it down and they
removed the audio Yeah because it's
harmful to the community yeah and it's
just such a weird but at the same time
and I literally saw a video of a girl
just in like a see-through shirt
bouncing her titties yeah and that
wasn't harmful to me
tell you something else you know what
Tick Tock knows my heart that's what
Tick Tock knows it knows your boy like
some tatas yeah I get it yeah you know
and so there's like that other set with
like Tick Tock I heard Tick Tock too
they're thinking about getting rid of it
in the United States in general well
that was a conversation that was on the
plate when Donald Trump was in
presidency it's coming again recently
yeah that's and that's one thing that I
completely agreed with him on is like
hey man look at the security risk of
what this app selling information right
I mean it's it's
China is basically harvesting that
information you know
um but
nobody nobody even [ __ ] remotely has
that thought when they're thinking about
Tick Tock yeah they're just thinking
about it as a platform it's quick
content you know where you get you could
go viral with just a [ __ ] dance video
so you try to make that dance video and
then you end up looking like a [ __ ]
loser who has no life and definitely has
no rhythm yeah and then you just expose
yourself and you got no [ __ ] views
that's that's what Tick-Tock is to me
like this weird like Tick Tock is
literally like I said Tick Tock is the
social media platform for talentless
people to fool people and thinking that
they're talented like I don't know how
many times like I've seen a video where
a girl just
um
voiceovers like a song and this dance is
like a shitty little dance and it has
like 400 000 likes or or not even the
[ __ ] dance they're just like looking
into the camera doing like yeah I don't
it's so cringe yeah it's so cringe for
me dude I don't get it like I literally
don't get it and I don't understand why
a human being would do that and then
love it oh like do you know why why they
do it because the [ __ ] views and the
likes they're getting it [ __ ]
inflates their ego you know it makes
them feel good it's the dopamine effect
they see the likes coming in they're
like like if I met a person right yeah
they go oh what do you do and they go I
do Tick Tock and I and I was like what
do you do on Tick Tock and they go I
just do what I'm like I would literally
look at them smile and I would walk the
other way
not because I just don't want to say
anything mean because if your talent in
life is you just mouthing words I
guarantee you our conversations are
going to be absolutely pointless well
that's you know that's the thing right
you just said it is that it's talentless
people these people don't have talent
but because maybe they're pretty or
handsome or whatever they just get the
following right and it's again it's just
so [ __ ] cringe for me for like some I
don't have tick tock on my phone I I
never did right
um and Tick Tock keeps removing my
accounts apparently I'm a harm to the
community
that's ironic your [ __ ] existence of
an app is the harm to the community you
know certainly I'm harmful to the tick
tock Community I have a I have another
Tick Tock and I just I post like every
once every year like for three four
months but yeah going back to the whole
like freedom of speech thing and and
less censorship yeah that's what he's
pushing for but like
ah
it's it's hard man because it's like
those very people
um and and some of these being like you
know crazy right-wing nuts and stuff
like that who they're just looking for
an excuse to be able to say the n-word
you know and it's like no don't censor
me like this is my opinion this is
freedom of speech and it's like
yeah but then there's also hate speech
too and I don't really have a problem
with hate speech getting censored now
the
um I guess the question becomes well
what is considered hate speech and who
deems it to be hate speech right and I
think those are some of the people that
Elon Musk has been letting go is like
some of those people who monitored those
things flash those things but this is
what happens too when
if the pendulum swings too hard here the
pendulum is going to swing back hard
here and that's what's happening there
is no moderation in this [ __ ] right
because I do somewhat agree with not so
much Elon but people who believe like
there's too much censorship now where
everything is offensive an opinion is
offensive a thought is a defensive thing
right so for example like
in the last two or three years like what
is the biggest argue what is the biggest
thing that has been talked about what is
a man what is a woman gender identity
there are everything is considered a
form of violence now
everything's like when you say this you
don't know what's going to happen to me
out on the street doesn't mean that's
just a form of violence yeah a lot of
people can agree or disagree with this
right but because there are such extreme
swings and thoughts and ideas and
nobody's willing to have conversation
you have somebody here where yeah maybe
these people on the Twitter they put
their personal feelings into this and
they want to censor these things that
personally hurt them so they have a an
extreme bias towards what they feel
about their personal life yeah and they
say that this is a represent of how
everybody should feel so yeah those
people I think should be [ __ ] fired
and now you have Elon on this other side
where he's like now I just don't want
any censorship at all which look I'm
kind of more on that side too but then
I'm not on the side too of like a lot
like like do we have to allow people to
say the n-word with the hard R I think
we can we could stop that you know what
I mean yeah there's certain things that
we could stop right like there's certain
phrases like I want to I don't know rape
you I don't think we need that yeah
right yeah
so because it goes here and here there's
no moderation in between and nobody
knows how to have a conversation with
people and everything is always there's
no facts now facts don't exist anymore
everything is opinion even science is
now considered an opinion
I don't understand that's why sometimes
like when I when I'm in this space right
and I've thought about it so many times
there are times I just never want to be
an entertainment ever again like I just
don't want to you know what because once
again it goes back to these celebrities
I [ __ ] hate celebrities yeah I hate
them so much because they think that
they are gods they think that their
opinions matter so much more than
everybody else they put and and they
just Pander to on the other side of
hyper liberal ideas right yeah they just
Pander to it oh is this the thing that I
can say so I don't offend anybody so I'm
just going to keep going down here and
they don't think about the consequences
right and when they do that they say one
[ __ ] up thing those people who are on
your side go and turn on you instantly
yeah because you are pandering to people
you didn't have any original thoughts
you didn't have any ideas you had no
Foundation to say the things that you
wanted to say and now that when you're
[ __ ] on that cross and they're
crucifying you you're [ __ ] now yeah
because you were pandering to a side
versus having your own original thought
odds and sticking to an opinion whether
it was right or wrong and that's why I
just I sometimes like being in
entertainment makes me so sad that's why
I like sometimes he's like what if I
just disappeared I think I'd be better
off no I I know exactly what you mean I
mean I'm not even in entertainment but
then when I just kind of look at
our society and our culture today
I just sit there and I'm just like dude
what the [ __ ] is going on what happened
man and look man social media is to
blame yeah you know it's a Black Mirror
we live in a Black Mirror yeah straight
up straight up it's it's Eerie how like
closer we're getting to a Black Mirror
episode you know how how it's our our
reality is becoming a Black Mirror
episode and
the thing that bothers me the most is
that
because people are just consumed by
their phones and by these apps that they
utilize and social media platforms they
utilize they don't even think there's no
like thought process there it's just
consumption and then it's like you're in
an echo chamber you know if you if you
believe in a certain idea or a certain
thing and that's what you're searching
and then the algorithm starts suggesting
that to you more and more and more
you're just stuck in this infinite Echo
chamber and I I know that's what I'm
saying I really wonder what happens to
this is why the thing I don't understand
about Twitter and like celebrities just
harping about this [ __ ] right
genius farts this podcast is brought to
you by
expressvpn I never go online without
using my expressvpn if you guys don't
know what that is guess what if you're
browsing online everybody can see your
personal stuff your [ __ ] and sell your
information and I don't want none of
that I want to browse the internet
without the stress of people using me
and selling my stuff well guess what
with expressvpn it keeps all your
information encrypted and secure
um so yeah you don't got to worry about
that [ __ ] and guess what most of the
time I didn't even realize I have
expressvp on because guess what it runs
seamlessly in the background and it's
available on all my devices I personally
use it on my phone because that's the
device I use the most protect your
online activity today with the VPN rated
number one by Business Insider visit my
exclusive link expressvpn.com genius and
you can get an extra three months free
on a one-year package that's expr
essvpn.com genius expressvpn.com genius
to learn more
genius brain by David so is brought to
you by betterhelp online therapy my
friends if you have not tried online
therapy you should try better help I
know at times
um we have these feelings where we feel
like we're in a corner or we feel like
we're in a dark place and even when you
talk to your closest friends family
members or girlfriend or boyfriend wife
or husband or whoever that you confide
in sometimes you need somebody outside
who can help guide you
um I feel lost a lot of the times too
I'm doing so many things that at times I
feel like I don't really focus on myself
and that's where my Better Health online
therapist comes in super affordable and
just very very accessible and when it
comes to something that I feel that a
lot of people need accessibility is
everything everyone deserves to feel
their best better help makes it easier
to get started as the world's largest
therapy service they've matched to
millions of people with professionally
licensed embedded therapists available
100 online all the benefits of in-person
therapy plus it's more convenient more
accessible and more affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
the therapist and then by clicking you
can easily switch to a new therapist any
time it couldn't be simpler no rating
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist get unstuck With
Better Health learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhealth.com
genius that's betterhelp
health.com genius
this podcast is brought to you by rocket
money my friends my lovely genius farts
are you wasting money on subscriptions
eighty percent of people have
subscriptions they forgot about maybe
for you it's an unused Amazon Prime
account or Hulu account that never gets
streamed you money wasting idiot there's
this great app I use that helps me track
all my expenses and because of it I no
longer waste money on subscriptions I
don't even use yes my friends you might
have heard of it it's called Rocket
money formerly known as true bill do you
know how much your subscriptions really
cost most Americans think they spend
around 80 a month on subscriptions when
they actually spend closer to 200 that's
a lot of money well guess what with this
app that I personally love using it
takes care of that for me it's called
Rocket money formerly known as true bill
my friends the app shows all your
subscriptions in one place and then
cancel for you whatever you don't still
want rocket money can even find
subscriptions you don't even know you
were paying for you may even find out
that you've been double charged for a
subscription to cancel the subscription
all you have to do is press cancel and
Rocket money takes care of the rest get
rid of useless subscriptions with rocket
money now go to rocketmoney.com genius
seriously it could save you hundreds per
year that's rocketmoney.com genius
cancel your unnecessary subscriptions
right now at rocketmoney.com genius
nobody's [ __ ] forcing you to be on
this platform you [ __ ] loser you know
what I mean it's like I can't believe I
have to come into Twitter and see this
stuff you don't have to be on the
platform nobody expects you to be on the
platform yeah if you disappeared off of
Twitter nobody would give a
one thing though well the only reason
why I still have Twitter and that I use
Twitter is
um street fights I love it I [ __ ]
love it no not for street fights for
breaking news if some world event is
happening it's like people are tweeting
about it people are putting a video like
even the the Korea incident and you can
read about it and then not participate
yeah yeah yeah I just I I look at it I I
use the platform to like get uh
real-time news and happening of what's
you know what's going on
um for that purpose it's very useful but
then everything else of all the [ __ ]
hate and the stupidity and just the
complete nonsense that exists there
I'm like ah boy here's the thing here's
the other thing I think maybe why I kind
of go towards the Elon side maybe a
little bit more is because there's still
an option on Twitter where you can
curate what you see and what you don't
want to see that's why my Twitter is all
jokes like any type of hyper serious
stuff there there are a couple people I
follow on Twitter they don't even know
who I am
I follow them because they're the
obsessive human that just wants to
comment on yeah on all the current topic
[ __ ] and lay that their lay their
opinion on everything I only follow them
so I have topics for the podcast bro you
know what's crazy though is that like
yeah every once in a while when I do pop
into Twitter for like news and stuff it
kept suggesting Elon Musk [ __ ] to me and
I said do not suggest this I don't want
to [ __ ] see what Elon Musk is saying
I don't give a [ __ ] what he's saying I
don't look at him the way a lot of these
millions of people look at him you know
it keeps still [ __ ] suggesting it and
it became more
um more suggested once he was getting
close to actually buying it out and I'm
like what the [ __ ] is going on here I
don't ever search for Elon Musk I don't
ever [ __ ] talk about Elon Musk I
think it's just because he's such a high
trending topic I know but I do not this
is like irrelevant to me do not suggest
I've done that multiple times for his
[ __ ] yeah but that's what I'm saying
like because it's such a high trending
topic other people who are in your
peripheral are still talking about them
so it's sneaking in somehow yeah that's
how it was with [ __ ] Andrew Tate
every time I watch a YouTube short
Andrew tape pops up at least one I'm
like dude I literally I don't want to
hear anything about Angie Tate I don't
have anything personally against them
yeah I just don't want to hear stupid
lisp yeah every time he talks about
something I don't want to hear it I just
don't care about his [ __ ] it's not
entertaining to me anymore so I just
keep seeing his [ __ ] I think with Ben
Shapiro for some reason Ben Shapiro is
popping up in all my [ __ ]
like I didn't want to hear his [ __ ]
squeaky little voice that's a voice I
definitely don't want to hear yeah just
guys angry about everything I'm like I
don't want to hear any of this [ __ ] but
you know like social media once again is
a choice right
um You Don't Have to participate in any
of this [ __ ] I know it's gonna make you
seem like quote unquote like a loser but
you know a majority of my friends from
back at home like in Sacramento they're
not on social media right they live
their regular lives they pop into
Instagram like if an engagement happens
or they want to post their kids they
rarely rarely ever post yeah they're
never on there yeah and I'm like oh
these are normal people right the other
people on Twitter who are constantly
tweeting 24 7 because they're waiting
just waiting and begging for somebody
just to suck their virtual big please
somebody please retweet this somebody
suck my [ __ ] digital [ __ ] validate me
yeah it's just the saddest thing ever
it's so [ __ ] sad man like I
understand I get it like you need
external validation but I tell you this
right now there's a reason why when you
don't get get those things it makes you
feel a certain way it makes you feel
like a loser
[Laughter]
look man if it wasn't for you know our
brand like I wouldn't have Instagram I
wouldn't I have like these social media
I mean again maybe I might have Twitter
just for the news thing but I generally
would not use social media I'd be off
the grid right I I like social media
like don't get me wrong I don't hate it
right I hate how people use it though
right it's the application of what and
and kind of like how they allow it to
ruin their lives it can be a great tool
and it's very entertaining like I said I
love street fights I just saw one
yesterday that was the most ridiculous
street fight I've ever seen dog one of
my favorite videos I've ever saw on
Twitter was two guys
smoking crack and one person somebody's
ass
Twitter yeah thank God for Twitter yeah
so look I understand I'm not [ __ ] on
social media because I hate it I love it
I made my whole life off of it right but
when you don't know how to control
something that's supposed to be a tool
and it becomes a poison to you then it
becomes a problem but that's what I'm
saying is that people don't recognize
that it's become a poison it's like it's
literally poisoning their minds but
they're just so consumed by it and it's
become so habitual that they're using it
without thought and that's my problem
with it is that like dick talk man oh
yeah I mean Tick Tock is a huge reason
to blame I mean we're seeing people
develop ADHD in real time right now dude
I dude I I recognize that in myself yeah
like when I started watching more shorts
and [ __ ] I I started having a trouble
focusing and it's been [ __ ] up my
work and now you're seeing people too
who can't pay attention and I've seen it
multiple times yeah and why do you think
that is because day in and day out just
swipe swipe swipe swipe swipe two second
swipe swipe sweat and it's like that's
what I'm saying you see you are seeing
them develop ADHD in real time that's
what's happening one of the videos the
type of videos that I [ __ ] hate are
cooking videos on Tick Tock because and
Instagram lately because everything is a
[ __ ] one second jump cut
I'm like dude I can't see [ __ ] yeah I
don't know what the [ __ ] you're making
yeah but that's the attention span of
these people right that's what you also
see too like I always [ __ ] on some of
these like YouTube short chefs not
there's a lot of great ones that I
follow and I [ __ ] with and I'm gonna
interview them on this podcast too I
think they do really great but those are
the people that I want to to have a lot
of shine because I think they're doing a
great job some people too and I [ __ ] on
these people where they they find a
recipe that they see online real quick
and they go let me teach you how to make
this you don't know how to make it don't
[ __ ] make it yeah don't make it and
they misrepresent Foods they
misrepresent cultures they represent
everything just because they want views
well that's the thing though is that
they have the platform to be
whatever it is that they're claiming to
be you know they're they're these uh
what's the word for it like
self-appointed professional at whatever
it is that they're doing and I've seen
that their food that they make and they
read the comments like oh that looks so
bomb I was like listen I know what look
I I know for a fact that food doesn't
taste good yeah I just know I know it
doesn't there's a lot of people who are
good at dressing look I have a friend
you know this friend too she's one of
those people that you know always posts
up her recipes and [ __ ] I've eaten her
food multiple times and I hate it
hate it so [ __ ] but but that's the
thing bro people can't taste through the
screen all their thing all they're
looking at is the presentation right
it's the same thing with fighting man
once you fight you know what's up when
you cook you know what's up right right
but people you know maybe the food might
taste like [ __ ] and and the recipe sucks
but they're presenting it in a way that
makes it look Instagram worthy you know
the gram worthy or like Tick Tock worthy
and it's like oh man that looks nice so
it must be good yeah and that's kind of
that's it how many people are actually
going to try the recipe probably not
that many right you know a lot of people
just kind of I wish sometimes like
Integrity mattered a little more and
integrity just it's slowly starting to
disappear that's why I always give [ __ ]
to my buddy [ __ ] Jason Chen his him
his shitty ass [ __ ] comedy videos not
even comedy videos like I said he's the
only person I know that covers music and
covers jokes
but not even Integrity though bro just
qualifications like what qualifications
do you have to be talking about this or
doing this professionally dude there's a
kid I know too duh that's such a good
thing to talk about just because
listen I've
kickbox on and off for what three four
years right have you ever seen me do a
tutorial on how to kickbox yeah
never you know why because I am not
qualified
yeah I might be able to do it here and
there yeah I am not qualified to teach
anybody [ __ ] besides somebody maybe how
to throw a jab in a cross and do some
stuff here and there yeah there's a kid
that I used to bring uh when we used to
train I used to bring him along and I
used I stopped ringing because I got so
mad I started being the [ __ ] out of him
because
he would talk a big game right and he
would do
um Muay Thai tutorials on how to do
stuff and I'm like
beat the living [ __ ] out of you today
like what qualified nasty yeah they
[ __ ] sit here and make a video about
how to do something that you've never
done in sparring I've never seen you
this is my favorite setup combo kick to
do in sparring funny I sparred you 10
times you've never been able to do that
[ __ ] but that's what I'm saying
everybody is a professional everybody's
a genius everybody's a prodigy and like
they're free like yeah even if people
call them out on the [ __ ] they can
still freely post it you know they could
keep posting tutorial videos keep
posting you know how-to videos
even though they have zero
qualifications even though they might be
completely butchering whatever it is
that they're showing how to do it but
they have the ability and that's the
difference that's the thing too that's
why like I don't think people understand
like why I repost or I post people that
I really like a lot because I want them
to represent people with integrity and
credibility speaking of I saw that
[ __ ] you gave our boy Brian dos reads
the shout out yeah I saw that video uh
before you posted it actually amazing
and I was like ah [ __ ] I remember when
we shot that because the the beginning
was was from our lookbook amazing yeah
from our first collection and see people
like that right it's like people like
that who [ __ ] put in the the work
paid their dues and has that raw [ __ ]
Talent deserve to get that type of shine
so I I understand completely and by the
way too this is not me saying that oh
whenever I create content I need to be
credible no you can create content for
fun yeah I think when you pretend like
you're a source of knowledge and
information
and you're very knowledgeable about
something you lie to your audience and
then you misrepresent things and people
are learning garbage from you right and
you like that's the issue that I have
anybody can go ahead and cook and say
hey I like this [ __ ] that's great I [ __ ]
with that too but when you like for
example like you you do that with um I
don't know let's say you're doing a
video about how to fix a car
you don't know how to do it and then
somebody's like you know what I'm gonna
try this out and they [ __ ] up their car
and you're like but I was just making
content yeah this is how you jump a car
you put it on the metal make sure it has
gas attack with them and then make sure
that you put one on your tongue because
your body is made of electrons and so
when you do that it'll recharge your car
this person explodes and then your
reason is like well you know I just I
was just making content yeah that was a
joke yeah and like I said I'm all for
that type of stuff always make content
try new things whatever but the snobbery
of thinking that you want to be a person
you want to be a person of of knowledge
and you want to teach people when you
don't know how to do things is stupid
and by the way that [ __ ] gets caught
really fast I know but everybody's a
self-proclaimed expert these days you
know everybody's an expert in everything
and they just think oh you know I read
one paragraph on this I'm an expert I'm
gonna talk about this you know or you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna give advice on
this or I'm gonna school people on this
and the worst part about that too and
this is for you people out there when
you clearly have just learned something
yesterday and then you make a post
shaming other people for not knowing
something that you learned yesterday you
are such a piece of [ __ ] that's the
worst like did you know about this a lot
of people don't know about this about
African culture neither did you it was
just Wiki that I could tell you didn't
know because you're reading off a piece
of [ __ ] paper yeah and you shame
people for not knowing things it's like
they don't know they're allowed to learn
you know who did that to me who okay
because I I posted that clip of or not a
clip the picture of the right way to
peel a banana and then it's the other
end the the top with the knot that's not
the right way to peel a banana the the
right way is the the tail end the bottom
I didn't know that and you know that
yeah and I came across it on the
internet and I was like oh [ __ ] I didn't
know that's the right way to peel a
banana so I shared that on my story of
like did you know right because I had
just learned it and came like man you
[ __ ] boom her ass bro
YouTube yeah
people been knowing that bro and I'm
like
viral video that
I mean he's like bro it's been like on
the internet forever none of that [ __ ]
in in elementary school really yeah yeah
I never knew that that was the right way
to peel the banana so I was just sharing
my newfound knowledge I wasn't claiming
to be an expert I just like did you know
you know I just found that out and then
this was like man you [ __ ] boom
I'm like hey bro I'm just trying to
share the [ __ ] knowledge wealth man I
just found out it's weird man like like
I said too I got I love the internet I
love what it does it's such a powerful
tool and maybe some people get tired of
me harping on this but I just want
people to have their mental health in
check because oh yeah it [ __ ] with your
mental health so much man absolutely
that game of comparison starts to eat at
you so much every day you are never
happy ever because you're basing your
happiness on what other people say about
you and I see it eat these kids up they
cry about it they think about suicide
they they feel like their their value is
zero because you're basing your value on
things that don't exist yeah people's
opinions about you change every day
somebody will call you a piece of [ __ ]
they'll give you five bucks and you'll
say that's a good guy I've seen it
happen so many [ __ ] times for sure
and and especially if they're basing it
on just so such like superficial things
they're basing it on the way you look
and all of a sudden like yeah I find you
hot but then you did something that
displeases me and now you're a piece of
[ __ ] human being you know the people you
know what the thing that Mario said
about me when she first met me she goes
done all your friends are so different
she goes none of your friends that I
meet are like each other they're all
different I was like how do you make
friends like the way that you do yeah I
was like they're different but they have
one thing in common yeah I said the
biggest thing in common is that they're
[ __ ] weird yeah and they know that
they're weird they're very confident
that they're [ __ ] Oddities right I
like people who have a strong sense of
self right and they own up to their
identity right you know why because
those people are the most trustworthy
because anytime that they speak about
stuff is truthful to who they are I
don't have to second guess who they are
I know like for example one of my
friends that she hates [ __ ] hates
this dude and I understand he's Rough
Around the Edges [ __ ] says the N
word hard
but like just he's just stuck in that
time because he went to the military
okay curses up a [ __ ] storm does all
this to the shields why do you like him
so much because that's how he is that's
how he grew up yeah he's authentic he's
authentic to himself yeah the thing
about him is like he's the one of those
dudes that if I was stranded in the
middle of a desert I called him up he's
dropping everything he's picking me up
and he's gonna find where the [ __ ] I'm
at to make sure I'm alive right he is
one of those human beings like the core
of this person is very [ __ ] genuine
he's Rough Around the Edges because he
had a very [ __ ] up life growing up but
he's a good [ __ ] person all my
friends are weird as [ __ ] but the one
thing that they have in common their
identity is very very sound they know
who they are I know that when they say
something I know that their next move I
know what their next move is I know I
know them you're right they're never
trying to please me they're not trying
to please other people they just do what
they do some of them are Geeks anime
nerds some people are [ __ ]
weird-hearted criminals you know what I
mean but I can trust them yeah because I
know what they say is honest even though
if I think that it's wrong or it differs
from what I believe at least I know what
they're who they are yeah you know yeah
it's funny because like you bring that
up about Mariel uh some time back like
we were talking about something related
to you and I was like saying oh Dave and
she's like since when do you start
calling him Dave I was like I call him
Dave all the time he's like I've never
heard you call them they I was like I'm
pretty sure I've been around you enough
times to like for you to hear me call
him Dave and she's like who are you
my identity as a person changes now
because you had this newfound Revelation
that I call him Dave you know she's
funny man yeah but you know yeah me when
we got to know each other like when she
I took her to weddings in Sacramento she
goes all your friends are of all
different ethnicity I was like what do
you mean because she grew up all of her
friends were Korean or Taiwanese yeah
she goes you have like people who are
like Indian they're Pakistani they're
[ __ ] you know Chinese they're [ __ ]
African they're black American uh not a
lot of white people Mexican you know
what I mean but she goes this is like
crazy like she's like it's like the U.N
yeah I'm like yeah like I I've never
judged People based on what they look
like how cool they are what they dressed
as they just were really good people
yeah and I've kept those friends for a
very long time one of the things too
like I don't give a [ __ ] what anybody
else says one thing that I know that I'm
very good at is keeping friendships so
if I've ever had to cut out a friend you
have to know that that person was a
piece of [ __ ] I've had the same friend
since I was [ __ ] like five years old
yeah right I've known Ray since I was
two right like I keep friendships for a
very long time I've now known edric for
[ __ ] 10 years right I keep friends
for a very [ __ ] long time in order
for you to leave my life you have had to
have done something terrible yeah like
[ __ ] terrible because I could
reconcile a lot of things yeah like your
core character as a human being has to
be rotten to the core for me to have cut
you out yeah like so
and I think that's like one of the
things Mariel noticed about me she goes
you have really good people around you
like your your friends are really
[ __ ] good and the people that you
have let go like they've are definitely
trash human beings I was like yeah
because I've I let my guard down I let
certain people in because based on what
other people felt about them yeah last
person I cut out was based on I I met
this person
uh through my friends and I when I first
met this person I remember I looked at
my friend I was like
I want you to keep this person away from
me I don't trust them and I think that
they are [ __ ] terrible yeah like oh
you don't know about their past history
they're actually really good and against
my better judgment I let this person in
my life and they [ __ ] up a lot of
things and I had to cut them out and
that's because I didn't trust my [ __ ]
gut feelings and for now on even I had a
conversation with these friends uh when
we hang out I was like they're like oh I
want you to meet you know a couple I was
like nope anybody you bring in my life
yeah I don't ever want to meet them
right I was like you are my friends your
friends are not my friends because you
have a habit of calling people your
friends way too fast right that's my
that's my really good really when you
meet them three months ago they're not
your friends you don't [ __ ] know
these people my dog right there bro
that's my I trust someone this
[ __ ] everybody's his [ __ ]
friend dude it's the most [ __ ] worst
quality about him yeah not that he's a
bad person but because he trusts
everybody yeah too naive too naive yeah
too nice oh this person's real why is he
good because what he did stuff for you
you know who you are like of course he
did suffer he wants something from you
yeah everybody's nice doesn't they're a
good person right and that's why there's
that saying is like if you really want
to know the character of somebody look
at who's there at their funeral you know
look at who shows up to their funeral
and I I think that is a good point to
make is that like yeah the people that
you have around you is indicative of
like yeah what type of person you are
you know you got a bunch of [ __ ]
thugs around you
chances are you pretty rough around that
[ __ ] too you know 100 yeah and I'm
saying too like you know this whole
social media gave me what Elon Musk is
doing like you guys are letting this guy
control like your emotions and your
feelings a little too much this guy is a
kid in a candy store he's he's Odd as
[ __ ] he's doing whatever the [ __ ] he
wants if you guys don't want to be on
his platform you don't have to be but
stop giving him power you know like and
I know it's hard but the more you pay
attention to this [ __ ] the more it grows
yeah and it's just like you could choose
to make this platform what you want to
make it and it's it look it's not
necessarily hard right they just have to
do it and and then they'll realize oh
you know what I'm not missing out on
anything you're not yeah and you might
even actually feel better for the as a
result of it because you might have an
inferiority complex seeing all this [ __ ]
that you see online and comparing
yourself constantly to them dog man I
don't understand sometimes too sometimes
when I meet people I can see it in their
eyes like I'll go to some some events
here and there that I'm kind of forced
to go to and they'll be like oh like oh
this I was like you probably know who
this person is like nope don't know who
you are right oh you think you're too
good it's that look like oh he thinks
he's too good it's like no I just don't
know who the [ __ ] you are I don't watch
[ __ ] on YouTube yeah you don't want to
watch on YouTube I watch this guy named
slavasres-menko he he's a chiropractor
in Russia that that gives Chiropractic
adjustments the half naked Russian girls
oh but it's not because they're half
naked yeah his chiropractors just are
very unique like he does his [ __ ] where
he cracks his lower back it's amazing
well you know that's a thing on YouTube
is the chiropractors and half naked
girls but like it's it's a very popular
Niche category oh I know there's some
like pervy [ __ ] chiropractors but I
like him because his cracks are [ __ ]
loud they're so good there are other
people who are probably just as good but
their audio [ __ ] isn't good so the
cracks aren't that loud it helps me fall
asleep so unless you're unless you're
[ __ ] uh Dr Gregory from Houston
Chiropractic unless you're Dr Raheem
yeah
um and you're or Dr uh [ __ ] uh Tyler
bigenhoe well I I think what you're
saying though uh sheds light on a good
point to bring up is that like you know
once you're in the content creation
space or like you're an influence or
whatever people assume that oh because
you also create content you consumed
content and so you should be aware of
everybody else and so it's like kind of
like an entitlement thing yeah
a narcissistic thing it's like nah bro I
just [ __ ] do this for a living but
and it's fun yeah so I don't know you I
don't know you I'm sorry what do you do
yeah oh you you uh go into a bath and
you put beads in it
yeah I don't [ __ ] know you yeah
that's cool man but
I'm sorry I've never seen your content
before what I'm sorry oh you walk around
and you throw pies in each other's face
and you start doing dance challenges I
don't [ __ ] know you
unless your buddy's DIY teaching me how
to fix cars and I'll never fix I don't
know you I watched some odd [ __ ] on
YouTube yeah I've dude there's there's
so many that I met I freaked out when I
saw him they're like I've never seen
somebody react the way that you have
meeting me I was like you know I I watch
your [ __ ] religiously yeah like I
[ __ ] watch your [ __ ] and it's odd too
because I'm not afraid of being a fan
like I like fandom because people are
fans of me I like to get that same type
of love and respect right so I have no
shame in that [ __ ] and um
I met this guy who does like carpentry
work and I was like
I was like naming all these videos
they're like I've never met somebody who
got this excited meeting me
I was like you don't like us like don't
you do comedy you meet other Comics I
was like I get that
okay cares yeah yeah I don't watch the
[ __ ] I watch your stuff but but how big
of a following does he have not that big
like over 100k over 100k for sure okay
okay I mean so he has a decent sized
fall yeah he's pretty decent yeah but I
think the way I freaked out I was like
dude I [ __ ] love you bro you know
what one of my rabbit holes recently was
was just looking up clips of rabbit
animals
bro I just you know it's so fascinating
what rabies does rabies is a [ __ ]
very very fascinating and lethal disease
man like it's
dude there's there's no cure for it
right if it gets too far right yeah
um it [ __ ]
um just controls you it takes over your
[ __ ] body you know it basically is
like melting your brain you have no
control and then so to see like this the
evolution of of like a being an existing
being being withered down to basically
nothing is really fascinating I heard
like the if you you catch it on early
before it gets too far that's right you
can go get the shot and you have to get
a shot in your belly button or some [ __ ]
I don't know where they got a place
painful as [ __ ] yeah I don't know where
they got to place a shot but yeah if if
like right away you get you know
bisposed yeah bit scratched or whatever
and they just give you the shot yeah and
and you suspect that that animal had
rabies then yeah you got to get to the
[ __ ] if I get bit by any [ __ ]
animal I'm going to get a rabies shot I
don't give a [ __ ] yeah give it to me
yeah yeah [ __ ] give it to me for sure
it's it's better to err on the side of
safe 50 with something like that because
it's a hundred percent fatality rate
otherwise you know what's one of the
videos I used to watch a lot I used to
look specifically people getting kicked
by horses
see that's what I'm saying there's
there's these things that are just for
whatever reason in your mind is just
fascinating and interesting it's not I'm
sure it's not because you you know Revel
in in the video of watching somebody get
seriously injured it's just that the act
of a horse kicking is just like it's so
powerful yeah and I'm always thinking
too like I don't know listen I don't
even like smoke like that right I only
take um CBD and Delta a and TC if I want
to sleep yeah it helps me relax or if I
before I Spar or something
well I'd be thinking of someone like I
always I look at horses and I'm like
what the [ __ ] was the person that walked
up to this thing and said I'ma ride you
like who the [ __ ] was that or or decides
the start of the horse what'd you think
was gonna happen bro I don't think you
understand how big a horse is like
they're huge there is a reason why
Carr's power is defined than horse
horsepower yes exactly why I don't think
people understand too how big [ __ ]
moose are right oh moose are [ __ ]
terrifying bro huge if a [ __ ] moose
comes after you man you pretty much just
say your prayers like the size of like a
short bus yeah bro they're huge they're
huge man like I remember uh forgot what
the [ __ ] I saw but I saw a deer I was
like oh dears are like the size that I
expected deers to be but like if you see
like the male stag yeah [ __ ]
scared the [ __ ] out of me and then a
moose is bigger than that
exactly
crazy that's why you don't [ __ ] with
nature bro you don't [ __ ] around with
that you're gonna find out you [ __ ]
around and find out to a wolf sanctuary
no I haven't talked wolves are huge
though I've seen a wolf people think
they're the size of dogs no they're
dwarf dogs no no so there's like
the wolves are descendants from these
other type of animals I forgot what
they're called I'm not sure they're
called lichens or whatever but they're
this is a distinct canine right and so
the one that's the closest to them are
gray wolves great wolves are huge
they're [ __ ] huge man so they're like
the size maybe even a little bigger than
Mastiffs yeah and Mastiffs when standing
up are like six and a half feet tall
right wolves heads are like the size of
our torso yeah they can [ __ ] kill
they used to hunt humans right like
these lichens they used to hunt [ __ ]
humans they could shred you apart for
sure yeah I I went to a wolf sanctuary
and these are like hybrid walls yeah and
they're not even as big as gray wolves
get yeah and they were so big it's I I
couldn't get inside because I was too
scared yeah I mean they're like oh
they're fine like you just got to make
sure you don't move or do any I'm like
no I'm not going in then I'll see them
on this side of the cage I'm okay yeah
I'm not trying to be the first test
subject that's a common misconception
that people think wolves are about the
size of dogs like a medium-sized dog to
a dog
yeah exactly these wolves [ __ ] dwarf
dogs so like the thing about wolves too
like I went to this Rabbit Hole like
researching wolves
um you can't reprimand wolves like you
do with dogs because they're not
domesticated right they do things in the
hierarchy of packs yeah so if you attack
them that's a challenge and it's a fight
right so if you try to chastise a wolf
no matter how long you've been they love
you their friend they'll shred you apart
because in in the wolf pack now that's a
challenge right so you can't spank them
hit them on the nose or tell them no
they will [ __ ] you up did you see do you
ever see the thing with the wolf whisper
no the dude who [ __ ] like lives with
Wolves no he he feeds on like raw or no
no he like Cooks uh liver and he puts it
in a pouch but he puts it inside of of
like a raw animal and then he
scrapes it out of there and eats With
The Wolves so that he's a part like
constantly part of the pack wears the
same clothes all the time that he
interacts so that the scent is there
um disgusting yeah ABS dude this guy is
a [ __ ] animal and I'm not is he uh
White yes
of course yeah he's I think he's
Australian and his passion is like
wolves and he he owns a wolf sanctuary
and all that but he's
um I think at one point he was the alpha
in his pack and yeah he like completely
like uh what do you call it made himself
a wolf a functioning wolf in that pack
doing the same thing as they do and just
watching it I'm like damn bro you must
really really [ __ ] love wolves and be
passionate about them [ __ ] that do that
kind of he has like scratches all over
his face because you know it's not the
wolves are trying to hurt him but like
when they're like playing or showing
affection they obviously human skin is a
lot more fragile than a wolf's coat
right why people be doing crazy [ __ ]
dude I just saw a video on Twitter shout
outs to Twitter once again yeah of this
girl she's like known to swim with tiger
sharks like specifically a tiger shark
that she's developed a relationship with
over the years right so this [ __ ]
[ __ ] she's about to dive in right and
she dips her head in to see the water
and then when she pulls her head out
[ __ ] shark comes at the biter face oh
my God and she's like
well as you can see the shark didn't
bear its teeth so it was just playing
the [ __ ] do you know about a shark did
you talk to it yeah this [ __ ] don't look
like play to me I didn't even know
Sharks play bro that's what I'm saying
the [ __ ] are you talking about man white
people crazy dude oh man that reminds me
of the story I [ __ ] told you at the
shoot about John hey guys look a giant
salmon yeah no seven bro that's a shark
man hey let me tell you something John's
been on this podcast
um you're an idiot John I used to
respect you a lot the fact that you were
in the ocean and then you looked down at
something and you said that was a salmon
number one not pronounced salmon number
two you're in the [ __ ] ocean Catalina
Island why the [ __ ] would that be a
salmon John exactly it ain't fresh water
bro
come back on this podcast I'm gonna call
you salmon so to give you guys a little
quick context on what the story is about
um uh we were in Catalina and we were
snorkeling and then um I was trying to
get out of the water and then the waves
pushed me and I was around like coral
reefs and it pushed me into the coral
reefs I got hurt and I was like oh [ __ ]
I can't get out this way so I swam
around an area like well into the ocean
that says do not swim Beyond this point
but that was like the only close and
safe way to get out of the water and
then so I'm swimming around and then uh
you know our friend John uh looks down
and he's like hey guys look a giant
salmon and then so I looked down and
it's a shark about it's about like five
six feet you know big I couldn't really
tell but it was about 10 15 feet beneath
the feet and he was circling around the
seaweed you know
and I was like I [ __ ] as a
[ __ ] that ain't no seven that's
a shark
get the [ __ ] out so everybody started
swimming as fast as they could right we
get out the water luckily nothing
happened and then um I get out and I see
why I understand why this shark was
circling on my leg was pouring [ __ ]
blood the coral reef just shredded my
[ __ ] knee and you know because it's
I'm in the water for that long too it
got softened and then so just like
shredded my knee I still have the scars
there too and literally my [ __ ] leg
just turned red because the blood was
just pouring out
and then I started walking and then what
did John say bro you have Kool-Aid on
here he said how you do that how do you
get a paint on your legs it's like were
you gonna share it can I get some
but yeah that that's why the shark was
circling underneath my foot but or under
our feet but John thought it was
I've lost salmon I've lost all respect
for this man
the fact there's like so many things
wrong with the story yeah I know well
guys that wraps up this episode of The
Genius brain podcast if you guys are
looking at this and you're looking
around you're gonna see the fall
collection it's all lined up oh yes sir
tote bag is dropping we got the socks on
uh I got the the cropped heather gray
pants on [ __ ] love these tangs I have
the Black version of it on right here we
have the new knit sweater that's coming
out right here as well so [ __ ]
comfortable yeah man for everybody who
has bought our secret society pieces
that kept the company going on for so
long thank you so much the company has
grown so much since then uh like I said
I want to make sure that uh everybody
has this in the closet one piece a
t-shirt I don't give a [ __ ] I just want
this to be a staple because we're a band
with the mission and I I really do hope
that you guys have continue to love it
anyways yeah and and like you know oh
the Corduroy had to [ __ ] fly right
yeah we got the cord hat we have five
different colors coming out with this
um I can't wait for the cord hats man I
can't wait by the way the colorways too
A lot of them yeah it's sick I mean we
we spent a good amount of time like
coming up with the color palette for
this season and we feel like we because
last season was the first time we
introduced colors dude it was a risk
yeah it was a big risk because people
who are familiar with us know that we've
always done black and white and you know
it's just it just stems from our like
personal aesthetic Choice like we like
black and white we like monochrome stuff
and that's it's reflected in the work
but you know we we decided to try to
shake it up a little bit and we're like
dude we don't know how the [ __ ] the the
audience is gonna receive this how the
community Community is going to receive
this and like people loved it and then
so we're like okay let's try some more
colors this time around
um we got colors like move you know we
got the turquoise color that you love
which people think it's a Navy but it's
kind of like in that Spectrum okay
turquoise yeah yeah yeah
um and then we got like brown which
we've never done that brown came out so
[ __ ] nice yep yeah when we were going
over it we're like okay this could go
one of two ways this color is either
gonna come out looking like [ __ ]
literally look like [ __ ] or it's gonna
be dope yeah luckily it came out really
dope
um so yeah we got these new colors this
Moss color here I don't know if it reads
on camera for the people who are
watching but we have different Speckles
of color here it's not just the green
like you're gonna see like a little bit
of orange like a little bit of a darker
green a lighter green and it creates
this kind of like moss looking color but
it's so sick you'll see it once you guys
get it once you see it in person feel it
in person you're gonna be like okay I
understand now why every time my [ __ ]
talk about [ __ ] I say I'm so excited
about this yeah yeah I'm not just saying
that I'm not saying oh I'm just excited
because I feel like I'm obligated to
Hype people up no we are generally or
genuinely excited about the new [ __ ]
we're doing because we're constantly
standing up if you love this [ __ ] tell
people about it tell your friends about
it because I know that when you're
walking around people are asking where
you get these pieces because listen I'm
trying to get us to do a [ __ ] denim
program already oh man we need some
[ __ ] money for that [ __ ] guys denim
denim is not an easy thing to do
especially if you're trying to do it
domestically and you gotta definitely be
on a certain level and have a certain
amount of capital in order to like
pursue that program especially if we
want to do it right which is with
everything if we're gonna do it we want
to do it right we want to do it legit
make sure that you guys are getting you
know the best quality we can possibly
offer you for the price points we sell
it at
um so yeah just to Echo what Dave said
please help us spread the word word of
mouth is you know best type of marketing
and yeah once we grow I mean look it's
really simple guys in order for us to do
the things that we want to do and do it
bigger and better we need more Revenue
we need more growth we need more eyes on
the brand and luckily it's been a great
uh growth process for us in this past
year but to get to where we're trying to
get to like because we talked about this
our goal is to become a household name
at some point you know and in order to
become a household name you can't be
[ __ ] operating with the Skeleton Crew
and like strapped for resources you know
um but we're getting there we're getting
there slowly but surely and
I'm always saying this but just always
full of gratitude and thanks and
appreciation for the people who've been
riding with us whether they've been
there since 2017 or they came on at some
point during the process we appreciate
you guys 100 because we know that we
wouldn't be here without you guys
well guys uh cop all that stuff you can
follow Ed at ed2 two and then you can
also follow secret society at
s-c-r-t-s-o-c-i-e-t-y check out the
website the fall collection will be
dropping soon or if not if it hasn't
dropped already uh genius print every
Sundays at 12 pm we'll see you all next
time peace yo